with CS2 just around the corner and
skins looking better than ever Cosmetics
have the potential to become even more
important to Counter-Strike than they
already are but it might come at a cost
it seems like valve is preparing to
develop skins that we have never seen
before but the question is how far is
valve willing to go and will we be okay
with what that looks like
alright before we get into the video I
wanted to let you all know that we
release an episode covering all of the
hype from the Snapdragon mobile Masters
thanks to our friends over at Snapdragon
Elite Gaming for taking us all the way
to Japan to experience this amazing
tournament where we witnessed one of the
greatest Underdog runs in brawlstar's
history make sure to check out the video
in the link below alright in the last
few weeks there have been quite a few
updates to the CS2 beta quality of life
upgrades map swapped in and out and much
requested fixes to movement but amidst
those gameplay oriented updates where
some interesting changes that might give
us a peek into what the world of CS2
Cosmetics might look like in the future
now some of those changes are pretty
uncontroversial for example the Zeus has
been added to the workshop this means
that artists can now create skins for
the Zeus and show them off to the
community why is this important well
it's pretty much one step away from
valve adding their own official skins
for public purchase if this happens I
can almost guarantee that the first case
is going to be called the Zeus case mark
my words in my eyes this makes a lot of
sense the community Community has been
memeing about this for years and since
the Zeus is technically a weapon why not
add skins for it well knowing that this
is the very likely outcome it opens up
opportunities for valve to release other
types of cosmetics and that's what leads
us to some of the more controversial
possibilities when CS2 first announced
one of the more eyebrow raising
additions or feet Yes in Counter-Strike
2 when you look down you will now be
able to see the lower half of your body
now the initial Community reaction was
of course to just make fun of it but
eventually people started asking why
sure it's cool and not that big of a
deal but when movement and b-hopping is
so important to your game why add
something that no one asked for and
might cause issues well valve's real
answer is probably something along the
lines of because we can if you don't
like it but if we put our tinfoil hats
on there's another potential answer one
to do with cosmetics
if we could sell them gloves why can't
we sell them shoes look at my feet
imagine I could wear football cleats or
something like that now of course adding
first person legs isn't that outlandish
and plenty of other games have them but
a few weeks after the initial
announcement data Miner gay follower
found something that actually adds
Credence to this speculation he
discovered lines of code that suggests
there will be separate cosmetic options
for things like tops bottoms hats shoes
and more there was even a line for pets
in contrast CS go source code only has
one extra line for Cosmetics hands now
although none of this has been confirmed
it's LED some people to believe that we
will see full agent customization in CS2
and to add fuel to this whole wave of
speculation in the most recent CS2
update valve added the ability to
inspect utility and since inspect was
added to better view your gun skins The
Logical conclusion is that valve is
adding grenade skins outfits skinsphere
flashbangs emotes if the data mining is
true all of this can potentially come to
Counter-Strike 2. now if you're new to
Counter-Strike or haven't played at all
you might be wondering who the
cares plenty of other games have
cosmetic options like this so what's the
big deal well Counter-Strike is not most
games and while it was never meant to be
a realistic military simulator there's a
certain precedent that has been set that
community members are used to and they
might not be too happy if it's crossed
you see over the years CS go Skins have
done a pretty good job at striking a
balance between being grounded and
things that people actually want to buy
sure an emerald green butterfly knife
might not be the most realistic but it's
a lot more believable than a gun that
moonlights as a fish tank or a literal
dragon and it sure as hell sells a lot
better than your run-of-the-mill
military camouflage that being said
valve does both if you want an AK with
your standard military desert camo you
have options if you want an AK that
looks like it belongs in a museum you
can get that too however even while
trying to stick to those values has
ruffled some feathers whether it's
holographics or anime girls not everyone
has loved valve's recent choice in
Aesthetics hell back in 2016 when gloves
were first released a lot of people
hated them it took a while for people
including myself to come around CS go
fans do not accept change easily and in
recent years valve has started to go
down a different path with their skins
if you look at the last 10 or so cases
those low tier standard camo skins have
started to disappear with the rare ones
only becoming more complex colorful and
a hell of a lot shinier and although the
community has mostly come to terms with
these new styles of skins there hasn't
been a new type of cosmetic in a very
very long time so if valve starts adding
a ton of new cosmetic options it might
alienate some of the core audience who
liked the game for its grittiness
although I personally don't think it's
going to happen many CS go fans are used
to this simplified stylization of gun
skins and knives and gloves and if they
go too far many fear the game will end
up like fortnite at the end of the day
whatever valve decides to add is just
going to print money that's the state of
the skin market right now so valve will
need to take a step back and think about
what they want their game to look like a
few years from now now if you're
freaking out and thinking about oh no
what are they going to do to my
Counter-Strike take a step back and
breathe because this can all just be a
big over exaggeration all of these new
additions could very likely be for
completely different game modes whether
it's custom servers or things like
Danger Zone on top of that valve loves
adding to their code that they
never end up using in the released game
don't believe me just look at the cut
content from CS go custom bomb codes
agent poses entire guns there are plenty
of things that never see the full
release so I wouldn't get too worked up
about this right now still it is fun and
scary to hypothesize about the micro
transaction hell that CS2 could become
where there's a cosmetic option for
every aspect of the game although I
doubt and hope it won't with that said
I'll pass it off to you guys are you
open to new types of cosmetics in the
game what do you want to see what do you
not want in the game let me know below
and as always stay safe and have fun
you just have like a beer koozie on your
smoke grenade you have like a Miller
High Life beer koozie better idea the
Terrace Molotov since it's like actually
a liquor bottle you get like you can
have like green apple Ciroc you can have
like a event sponsored by by alcohol
companies and their alcohol is the
molotov this is the the green apple
Ciroc Molly of the game